hey how's it going brahs welcome back to
resident evil 7
I didn't think ever claimed this so soon
again but haha they released a DLC hold
other shoe out okay we'll start with
banned footage that's a pretty good
title here we go I guess they could have
just released this with the main title
but thinking how soon they release it
better
I appreciated my little girl extended
it's always fun to revisit a game but
you finished and hey you know if I don't
have to wait that long in between I'll
take it
let's play nightmare what's that [ __ ] is
it
where am i oh ah it feels like a demo oh
my god what is happening gotta be [ __ ]
shitty
what oh no oh no oh no no no survival
until dawn what does that mean
what the [ __ ] is this zombies I'll take
the shotgun and I'll take some shotgun
shells how much do I weigh we're doing
all right now we start up safety first
everyone compactors for doing a steady
amount of sprint oh let the game begin
bro oh we're in the water [ __ ] area
what is this until dawn rip up all right
okay I got it
I can't open anything now I can [ __ ]
this is creepy dude this is well creepy
Jesus Christ there's a bomb there can we
activate it hundred wires okay so far no
enemies but we're doing okay
how much scratch have we made 100 okay
maybe we can install the turret now okay
this is a lot different than I thought
it would be what the [ __ ] is happening
shotgun is the way to go man [ __ ]
everything else 500 or 600 oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] what does that mean great
fantastic okay well I think this is a
really fun time waster and like if you
want to play more of Resident Evil
that's a really cool way to play but I
think what we are after it's the place
of the bedroom which I think it's more
of a story oriented thing I'm not sure
though man that got me I got me going
man I forgot I forgot how [ __ ] freaky
this game is
oh [ __ ] what is happening here yeah this
is definitely what I wanted to play okay
that's cool a little bonus
oh god it's never a good way to wake up
is it never a good way at least we have
one hand free you can still fap we can
still fap everyone we're [ __ ]
yeah mommy you made me breakfast sleep
well darling
oh yeah mommy our daughter really
oh [ __ ] hope she wants you to be a big
brother
oh don't get too excited don't jump up
and down just yet you don't want to be
part of this family you got it eat lacks
and um I'm actually Paul uh-huh I had a
snake that smells good down it it smells
so good but I think it's embarrassing he
wanted that and I'll take those things
off and go out and play okay okay all
right you gotta eat all of it
wow that looks delicious
wow this looks delicious really it looks
great I could probably take taker in a
kind of [ __ ] chokehold if she's that
close wait and I have one hand free is
there anything else to eat mr. hazing L
see you don't need nothing else
now eat your goddamn supper I'll eat
your ass if you come back late okay all
right well I guess we gotta eat I guess
we can escape from the road that's why I
love these kind of escape [ __ ] it's so
cool
okay we got a spoon high part I got to
do something
no [ __ ] [ __ ] dude all right so it's
pasta we just got to use well that was
easy
okay
hey aren't you gonna eat hey Elaine Oh
amnesia the doctors and there is
something on the puzzle on the slider
okay am i beautiful a strong poll might
get it open okay some satanic altars I'm
assuming this store doesn't even open I
were just gonna just gotta be another
way out of here I know I know it's a
Bradbury an untitled painting hey it's a
spiders but they will attack me we need
a lighter oh my god I'm not touching
that
oh you stay off the [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm
gonna touch him that the lighter bye bye
spiders
I need something hotter okay so we need
to lift something maybe what is this I
can't high parapet I think you might
remember me it's me Jack safety guy
I missed you from my cut I can't really
I can't do it I could just okay well
that's just good fun hey it's a watch
it's an high-quality watch okay uh-oh
there's a lot of stuff to mitigate some
kind of door beneath the bed oh yeah
we're in granny's room maybe we can dig
something out of the food oh what a
lovely food really know what do you
think whoa I'll have another spoon
please
shut that [ __ ] up this is cool I liked
it
all right ah anything okay we can enter
the clock oh my god okay and then set
that another paint hey whoa oh [ __ ] Ren
is gonna come back at me
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] let's go back go back
what was that noise nothing granted just
enjoying my food can't let her see
husband out of bed
did I have to hide the lantern again
[ __ ]
[ __ ] maybe I should have hid the lantern
oh my god I [ __ ] up okay
I just realize [ __ ] oh god put it back
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
wait wait wait wait wait oh I might [ __ ]
up here maybe I forget something hey
it's you now hold on Jess
now hold on now excuse me oh oh oh
that's Rory didn't open itself this is
what you get Oh
I can't really show you like crazy oh my
god you know I I enjoy that I am happy
to die there okay but the drawer I get
them open up lights up
okay I'm not quite sure like what I need
to do just okay
what's the drawer back in I suppose she
won't mind if I take that what the hell
is all that noise
I didn't do anything mommy I didn't do
anything my god oh my god she's coming
in or what hey how are ya oh oh oh no I
low [ __ ] time yeah now hold on hmm well
everything's change in order
thank you mommy and may I say your anus
tasted delightful I finished the whole
thing come on now
eat up I made that just for you I know
but you see don't worry I'll be back
real soon
of course not oh I I hope so because I'm
not doing anything weird at all
are we ha ha trick that [ __ ] God um all
right we're going out this is stressing
me out I don't know the element of
someone just randomly appearing while
you're fiddling with [ __ ] man it reminds
me of when I was a kid get the lantern
okay now what do we got we got one
painting and we know there's one
painting over here oh god shut up spider
all right okay
we got a painting their painting see
[ __ ] did I oh [ __ ] okay that obviously
goes there that obviously goes care and
you know I oh my god
oh my god what is that what is that
suing needle can I close this how okay
okay I can okay okay put it back let's
put it all back I think the circle one
there right let's just in case just in
case I'm going to put you back as well
if I ain't trusting anyone and a you all
do spiders needle hole is it doing it us
looks but don't think it make very good
weapon I was not about to think that can
we we can put that there
same as all the other clock of course
okay so I don't know what the [ __ ] the
time was [ __ ] I should have made a note
shouldn't I
okay I can still answer okay so it's
12:00
it's 5:00 5:00 in the morning can I read
the time I don't I don't know okay let's
just let's just do this and see what
happened that looks like a pregnancy
test thing not that I would know what
that looked like
Oh Oman Oman what have I done
and what the [ __ ]
first deaf friend making that noise not
me mommy not me mommy [ __ ] okay let's
make sure that we don't [ __ ] up enough
give it no no go back go back
Lubin bed i wonder how she'll react if
oh god we got to put this back as well
cut [ __ ] [ __ ] just freaking me out dude
freaking me out mommy get your fat ass
in here girl get your sexy ass yeah hey
oh you got me a treat mommy why what did
you have for me this time girl she knows
just what I like her milk juice that is
disgusting I am sorry what is longing to
me thank you mommy
it was delicious mmm no bet you smell
like heaven smelt especially for me ah
no you shouldn't oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh been
in here no oh oh [ __ ] I thought I know
just my imagination
oh yeah I figured you still had eaten
yet so I brought something else for you
alright thank you thanks ding whoa a
park Thank You Manny [ __ ] [ __ ] hater
what do we got
who the [ __ ] are these people Oh got a
lot of home cooking hey dude don't make
comment for me hey a fork a stove we
should at least try it you know it's the
polite thing to do that is probably a
paprika wife and some [ __ ] to try you
lose a little bit of health - that's
cool ok so that I noticed there was
something on the fort that was design
wasn't it inspect it that's not inspect
tool
started okay so snake what's on this
Apple okay what's the third one though
legit don't know what the third one is
for perhaps we can just guess it so I
mean I'm just guessing at this point
it's not a very good way to do it is it
okay [ __ ] okay well we're gonna have to
rethink there any other form of cutlery
in here
do we have any more cutlery from mommy
[ __ ] I don't know what can I possibly do
maybe the needle is just some no needs
fuel saw Fox say okay where do we find
fuel for a [ __ ] liner
let's do there's all kinds of [ __ ] here
dude come on man now you can break over
with that's soap oh no oh [ __ ]
are you serious it may be broken I'm
[ __ ] now I'm [ __ ] because the
[ __ ] thing will go back No hey got
him got him okay okay we're fine what do
we got in here
okay we got a cinema we got a another
one of these the lantern hook is fixed
evolved a cork a cord huh hey yeah hey
yeah this is the key we need right okay
okay okay okay okay okay
four go for it how am i doing that ha ha
ha ha then that didn't make any sense at
all yes we need that close close it
close it ok and then we close this door
we close everything we don't change
anything mommy doesn't like change
mommy's just like precious YouTube
commenters
make changes here I don't like it
unsub wait do after have to combine them
first
yes sir yes a baby yes it may be sexist
Texas to drop me and you burn that
[ __ ] spider hell yeah
goodbye oh [ __ ] dad and I wasn't doing
anything bad gotta get back I know I
know we have to get back got to get back
shake that ass okay I believe that was
it oh my god I'm so paranoid right now
did I did we lock the door after us how
much time do we have
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm gonna be so pissed if I
[ __ ] it up now I'm not enjoying this
dang it whoops meaning the [ __ ]
well you don't look at the lock oh now
hold on don't look at that lock don't
look at the lock don't look the line
don't look at the hook
please do not oh oh oh that's roar
didn't open all belching dryer bad boy
Clancy ah [ __ ] me you were out of bed
were you little piece of [ __ ] I was just
frightened you get low no I wasn't don't
give me that I know when somebody's been
touching things they are supposed to I
can touch your titty I get it it was
Lucas no it wasn't me it was Lucas he
was just in here a minute ago
please God please work Lucas Oh Lucas I
thought I told that boy wasn't allowed
to have you yet uh I'm glad to clinch my
ass
tithi
I saw that was so sings like a you act
out here where she she's 100% going to
kill it Fred she's 100% going to kill us
you know I would just find a way to kill
myself at this point because honestly
I'm not too happy about this okay I
couldn't even put the lock back so
there's no way [ __ ] drawer you [ __ ]
me dude [ __ ] you for five I [ __ ] hate
you you [ __ ] shock it used to be
better before now all you do is complain
you just complain poor powerful and
don't like it don't not too happy about
it
oh yeah the cooks good okay okay okay
okay why am I doing this how am i doing
this am i right
how am i doing that with my other arm I
don't even know why I need that I can't
place it back [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh great how
the [ __ ] was I supposed to find this are
you [ __ ] kidding me
that's ridiculous okay now then we have
the knife we can cut up the tape
excellent beautiful oh it's so
satisfying to do that every time
just put the line and then
painting oh wow
yeah this looks sad this looks correct
you're a fork oh god this is hard so
sensitive yeah yeah huh I say yeah I
said I yeah yeah okay next one don't
have a lot of time brush we don't have a
lot of time
oh god oh god I'm scared I am oh [ __ ]
it's upside down
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] there we go hey yeah
yeah I was a little awkward I'm sorry
take this back to where it belongs
take the Schnitkey and get that [ __ ] out
of it I think we're our own Oh are you
[Music]
quick quick use your head I'll use the
night
[Music]
oh I know I'm sorry mommy say anything
I'm sorry mommy
lobby lobby well yeah that was so cool
[ __ ] yeah coming soon
alright that was really fun I really
enjoy that I hope you enjoyed as well if
you did please drop a like I appreciate
it and it's always let me know if you
want to do Ethan I think that looks old
Ethan must die or something like that
anyway thank you for watching stay house
impressed